[Applause]
[Music]
when she was five i put her in her first
dance class they would put her in front
a lot she just like had a lot of stage
presence i just recognized that she had
something there honestly i think about
myself i'm fun to watch too and
sometimes when i look in the mirror i
just kind of have party with myself
kaya
it's okay
[Music]
i am
excited
to tell you
that you
are the very very first
member of x omg
[Music]
this week not only has kaya stepped out
of kenley's shadow she has stepped out
of everyone's shadow she can sing on
stage she can dance on stage she is a
pop star she makes x omg cool right now
you did it
[Music]
i put her in dance because i always
wanted her to be in dance and that's
when we seen the fire come out of her
and we knew that it was a passion her
name's going to be well known they're
going to be like oh that's brooklyn
brooklyn
congratulations
you're the second member of exomg
congratulations brooklyn
everyone went out on stage today and
gave an amazing performance but
brooklyn found her confidence and she
performed on a level that was unreal and
i just couldn't wait one more week to
tell her she was an official member of x
omg
we did it
oh you did it girl
oh my lashes hold up
oh my gosh
my heart is like
like my daughter just made the pop group
she's the new member
she rises she is the cream of the crop
she's at the top of her game we're the
wrong people to mess up we are the wrong
people to mess with for sure we're not
scared come on we're ready for you
because we're practiced we're costumed
we're highlighted we're glitz and we're
ready to go
everything you've done
has been with hard work
and perseverance
and dedication
i
know you're the fan favorite
and i want to tell you that
you're the next
oh my permanent
i can't wait this is hot oh my god
oh my god
oh my god it doesn't feel real like
i have the jacket on and i'm the third
member of the group like
omg
i told emg
i have no words congratulations
thank you so much i literally
thought we were going home today
we got a good little group going so far
yep
i know leah's had a hard week i know
it's been up and down but she has shown
drive a good attitude i want to give her
her jacket because even though she
doesn't start out the song
sometimes it's about who you are as a
person
and what you bring to the group
as a team player
dallas can sing dallas can dance i think
that she's everything that jess is
looking for i want to brag
but
i feel like i'm a beast and i'm
awesomely good dallas
i think tonight you were an angel on
stage
as hard as it is to bring the house down
with a ballad you did
and you did it your way
and i hope tonight when you go to bed
you sleep in your exo mv jacket
[Music]
it's my dream come true
i think she does feel ostracized a lot
because you know she does get a lot of
attention my daughter is good and and i
get that i understand that i go full out
like i always am so big
[Music]
we want this really bad
my actual name is tamara
and i'm very very tiny
so everybody just started calling me
tiny teeth i'm not
an acrobatic dancer i'm a hip-hop dancer
and the fan kicks and the splits it's
just not my thing
for weeks
we've talked about numbers
i look at my daughter and i think one
thing
we listen to what we wanted to do
[Music]
[Applause]
all six of you
[Applause]
[Applause]
my legs are still shaking
inside i am jumping up and down but i
also kind of feel like i've been hit by
a truck you guys i could not be prouder
of you every single
one of you but now that you're here
i have to i call it put the hammer down
doesn't mean i'm gonna be mean it
doesn't mean i'm going to be crazy but i
mean business
get ready for your new life
[Music]
[Music]
you